[Musique]
je suis sûr qu elle m'écoute à salir par
une particularité chez moi mon accent
oui mais ce n'est pas de cette
particularité que je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui
chaque année j'ai participé au plus
grand salon dédié à la téléphonie mobile
à barcelone
ce salon international qui fait
intervenir les producteurs les
fabricants et les utilisateurs
les vendeurs de la téléphonie mobile et
plus globalement de ce qu'on appelle la
mobilité c'est-à-dire tous les acteurs
qui participent à l'élaboration de ces
petits gadgets canadore comme les
téléphones les tv les tablettes mais
aussi les voitures connectées les
maisons connecter les vélos connectés
etc etc
si par hasard vous êtes à barcelone dans
cette période là vous aurez l'impression
d'être au tournage d'un nouveau film men
in black
des sommes qui balisent les rues de
barcelone un costume noir et moi au
milieu de tout ça je me sens un peu une
espèce en voie de disparition
cette année les pourcentages des femmes
qui on assistait à ce salon était devant
pour ça mais ces chiffres tiennent
compte aussi les hôtesses vous savez ces
jolies femmes qui vous disent bonjour à
chaque moment que vous se rapprochait
onesta elle sachant qu'il ya own ou
douce aux thèses par exemple on pourrait
imaginer combien de femmes est
réellement impliqué on assistait comme
on nous parle d'innovation
on a toujours à l'esprit ces petits
robots qui se bouge est qu'ils se
parlent et qui sait traduire qui sait
faire le ménage bref c'est tout faire
mais ces petits robots a progressivement
laissé la place aux autres objets comme
les fameux smartphones qui bouge avec
nous qui parle qui traduisent qui pour
le ménage on n'est pas encore là
l'innovation fait partie de notre
quotidien
est ce que vous vous êtes déjà demandé
qui se cache derrière cette innovation
il existe quatre domaines les sciences
la technologie l'informatique et les
mathématiques
et il se trouve que dans chacun de ces
quatre domaines la présence féminine y
est très très faible
autrefois les secteurs numérique et
technologie était considéré au secteur
indépendant mais petit à petit ce
secteur est devenu indispensable pour le
développement de tous les autres
secteurs
douze acteurs à part élevée nous
transversale je pense si on le regarde
déjà ou fortes inégalités fort hommes
femmes dans le monde numérique et
technologies à l'avenir cette inégalité
va s'éteindre dans tous les autres
secteurs
je pense que parvenir à une mixité dans
les mots numérique et technologie
aujourd'hui c'est la garantie d'arriver
à une mixité dans tous les autres
secteurs d'activité vraiment pourquoi
aujourd'hui il est si difficile de
trouver une mixité à l'innovation
on pourrait penser question question des
capacités alors levé la main ceux qui
pensent qu'elle les sommes sont plus
forts que les femmes n métiers
scientifiques et technologies à bravo
quelques noms en effet de garder leurs
résultats des taux de réussite par
exemple de vacciner fiq filles et
garçons ils sont des résultats
similaires
mais la proportion des mentions bien et
très bien et légèrement supérieur chez
les filles on va casser les filles se
débrouille plutôt bien mêmes elles sont
supérieures au moment du bac que les
hommes bon comme on explique les
contrastes entre ce résultat et leur
orientation professionnelle
personnellement je je pense que l'ati
tout y est pour beaucoup
ce que j'appelle la petite tout c'est la
prise de risque et l'innovation est une
prise de risque constante il existe on
bien travis tradition de protéger les
petites filles à des prises de risques
par exemple ça m'arrive souvent d'un
tendre à l'expression garçon manqué
lorsqu'une petite fille agi de façon
énergique décidé et courageuse
qu'est ce qu'elle va faire cette petite
avec cette remarque
on pourrait aussi penser que les sommes
en plus affinités à ce type de métier ça
nous ccim possible d'affirmer cela
tandis que filles et garçons ne seront
pas les mêmes chemins d'éducation et
stéréotypé à la maison à l'école ou plus
globalement à la société via vous
propose son jeu et je pense que vous
tous connaissaient sept sites internet
vous pouvez faire la location d'un à
part d'une taxi d'une voiture et se
traite maintenant fermez les yeux et
imaginez la personne qui est derrière
l'ordinateur en fait un train des
programmes 1,7 site internet
quel est son apparence vous savez cette
personne en tête
je pense que plusieurs d'entre vous on
imagine une personne avec cet appareil
est oui nous sommes en pleine de
stéréotypes
car sachez que cette personne pourrait
sembler à moi par exemple
en effet c'est mon travail je suis ce
qu'on appelle data scientist ou
scientifique des données pour ce que
veulent les français là date assaillants
c'est tout nouveau métier qui se
retrouve au milieu de l'innovation
actuellement nous autres dates
assaillants this nous sommes capables
nous sommes experts d'aller donner vous
a rappelé lionel et de téléphone les
lyonnais de vos maisons
les lyonnais de sites internet les
données qui sont partout
ce nouveau métier l'apparition de ce
nouveau métier est venu à vannes même
qu'est une formation diplômante existe
c'est à dire que l'innovation n'est
tellement innovantes qu'elle a dépassé
la phase académique
les entreprises sont novices ont une
audience de data scientist alors que les
métiers n'existait même pas mais les
personnes avec les profils
correspondants elle sexistes est ces
profils ses expériences matin
statistique en informatique et appliquer
cette expertise côté business
mais c'est aussi et surtout les goûts
pour toujours à prendre car il faut se
synchroniser à la vitesse à l'innovation
personnellement il se trouvait que
j'avais plus fière de ses compétences
mais les compétences ne font pas tout
pour en arriver là il est nécessaire
d'avoir une éducation et au contexte
favorable et cette question se pose
notamment si vous faites aux femmes pour
ma part
il ya un petit avantage mon père il
était mathématicien chercheur en
informatique
donc j'ai grandi au milieu des boîtes de
cartes perforées et des ordinateurs
monochrome je me rappelle même avoir
appris les codes binaires tout petit
laid courage c'est ma mère qui me l'a
transmis être une femme célibataire en
charge des deux filles dans son pays
très mature comme le mexique n'était pas
une tâche facile
et là de vraies preuves en force de
caractère peu commune pour pouvoir
évoluer dans un milieu aussi masculin
comme celui de la politique
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que young modèle
des familles en ce single yeah mais non
rien grande mère à l'époque de la
révolution mexicaine à l'âge de 7-8 ans
elle est en charge des sorties raquettes
de nourriture car sa mère craignant que
ces cinq personnes soit un relais pour
les forces révolutionnaires de panjwayi
ya les contextes de cette petite fille a
fait d'elle une femme avec un fort
caractère qu'il a permis de faire tout
ce qu'elle voulait dans la vie cobaye
simple partir tout seul
démarreur nouvelle vie à la ville de
mexico ou à l'âge de 15 ans pourquoi pas
faire une tournée avec sa troupe de
théâtre
devinez où elle est la grande mer
finalement j'y crois que je dois
beaucoup à cette personne et à ma mère
elle me rappelle lé courage donc
qu'elles sont de faire preuve tout au
long de sa vie et elle est ce pire la
femme que je suis de façon personnelle
et professionnelle alors c'est vrai
qu'il ya plein d'initiatives et c'est
une très bonne idée que les entreprises
fassent des efforts pour arriver à une
mixité dans les domaines scientifiques
technologie diaries et le matin mais
petit problème il n'y a pas suffisamment
de candidates
alors comment faire
pour charrier cela nous avons tous pour
la jouer pour une société libre des
jugements des stéréotypes et pour
laisser aux saint phalle la liberté
d'évoluer dans les domaines où une
personne de qualité sans distinction
aucune
par exemple la prochaine fois que nous
entendrons dire qu'une petite fille ou
un garçon manqué essayons plutôt de lui
dire qu'elle est courageuse les
dynamiques et qu'elle a toutes les
qualités pour devenir un futur l'hiver
pourquoi pas dans le monde à
l'innovation
on notera qu simple si on ne veut
acheter aux joueurs une femme
privilégions les jouets qui ne font pas
d'illusions deuxième gland et qui
d'ailleurs sont plus éducatif est
surtout mon trône aux filles et garçons
des images des femmes fortes avec des
histoires incroyables
car je pense monsieur dan que c'est le
moment de réformes atteint les disques
durs de notre société
merci
[Applaudissements]